welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and I gotta say
Scream 6 has definitely made it into my
top three of the screen franchise it's
definitely the gory's bloodiest stab
Fest so far and we gotta talk about that
ending if you haven't seen the movie yet
this is your spoiler warning hit pause
on this video and hit your local theater
because you do not want this twist
spoiled for you although you might not
want to bring any casual acquaintances
with you because ghost space is always
someone you know
and before we get into it a quick
reminder to check out nerdriot.shop
where you can always grab the latest and
greatest in new rockstars gear including
our latest designs inspired by the
Mandalorian support the channel and
check out all of our merch options at
nerdriot.shop now let's get into the
Scream 6 ending explained as many meets
Martin so eloquently explained
undoubtedly making her Uncle Randy proud
the requel and recall sequel of the
scream franchise played by new horror
movie rules and because Scream 6 is the
second of their equals it has to mirror
Scream 2 in tone while seamlessly
transitioning between Legacy characters
like Gail weathers and Kirby Reed and
New Blood like Sam Carpenter her younger
half-sister Tara and siblings Chad and
Mindy Meeks Martin like its predecessor
Scream 2 Scream 6 also takes place on a
college campus where Tara like Sydney
Prescott before her is trying to put the
killings behind her and live a normal
life Sam also tries to Sock Gail right
in the kisser just like Sydney did after
finding out that Ms weathers embellished
some truths in her latest story but Tara
did get the final Blow The Killers also
end up being people that the core 4
friend group are acquainted with plus an
older ghost-faced parent of a ghost face
thrown into the mix to parallel Mrs
loomis's reveal at the end of Scream 2
but to talk about the ending of Scream 6
we gotta cover some information we
learned in the first of the week we'll
Scream 2022. the killers at the end of
Scream 5 were revealed to be Sam's lying
cheating murderous boyfriend Richie
Kirsch and his real girlfriend Amber
Friedman Richie and Amber were rabid
super fans of the in-universe stab movie
franchise and met online or they
discussed their disillusionment with the
direction of the series after stab 8
failed to meet their expectations the
two decided to prompt A requel
continuing the narrative and heavily
drawing from the plot of the original
scream from 1996 by tormenting Sam Tara
Sydney Gail Dewey and Tara's high school
friends we knew that Richie was a toxic
know-it-all Fanboy but until Scream 6 we
didn't fully understand how deep his
worship of stab and its IRL Inspirations
went Richie wasn't just collecting stab
Funko pops and casually enjoying dead
Meats kill count videos it turns out
that prior to his death he and his
father managed to collect all of the
crime scene evidence in memorabilia from
all 39 previous murders including each
ghostface mask but like Sam it turns out
that we didn't know everything there was
to know about Richie either like I said
a second ago mirroring the reveal that
Mrs Loomis wanted to take Sydney out for
killing her precious son Billy in
self-defense it turns out that Richie's
father sister and brother have dawned
ghostface's signature style to get
revenge on Sam for stabbing Richie 22
times and blowing his brains out officer
Bailey sex positive roommate Quinn and
virgin nice guy Ethan had been planning
to attack Sam and her crew for six
months hoping to simultaneously clear
Richie's Name by Framing her and Carry
Out Richie's deepest wish to
reinvigorate the source material for the
next great stab movie this bloodthirsty
vengeful Trio know the best way to get
the public to believe that Sam was the
true Mastermind behind Richie's killings
is to falsely cancel her before making
it appear that Sam's stabby Loomis DNA
took over prompting her Killing Spree
Gwen Wars dumacher's Old Mass to kill
Gail's nameless eye candy boyfriend and
stab Gail then Mindy on the train Ethan
put on Nancy loomis's mask to kill the
folks at the bodega and Annika he also
stabbed Chad who miraculously survived
reminding us all of Dewey's multiple
previous near misses and Kirby who he
shanked in the exact same spot on her
abdomen where Charlie Walker knifed her
and screamed for it's also fitting that
he dons Nancy's mask as he too uses an
alias to conceal his true connection to
the previous killer it's not elaborated
on but seeing as officer Bailey was the
only one unaccounted for on the night of
the Halloween parties he was responsible
for the ghost face on Ghostface murder
of Jason and Eric he also was likely the
one to face knife Sam's therapist seeing
as she told him that Dr Stone was her
Alibi that night it's almost Springtime
you know the time of year that's kind of
known for smelling like fresh flowers
instead of slushy gray snow if you want
to be a part of the fresh fragrance crew
you want Samford Stanford is a fragrant
Subscription Service making it the
perfect place to begin or deepen your
relationship with fragrances their
reimage mentioning everything about how
to discover shop for purchase and even
experience fragrances Stanford lets you
choose a new designer fragrance to try
every month for just 17 and every month
you get to pick what you want to receive
so there are no surprises they have
perfumes and colognes and a ton of
unisex options with each fragrance
you'll get a 30 day supply so you can
try out fragrances before committing to
a full-size bottle zenberg carries
Brands like Prada Gucci Versace as well
as Indie labels like Skylar heretic and
confessions of Rebel your fragrance is
an opportunity to express your
individuality and scentbird selection
gives each and every person the power to
express themselves through fragrance
this month scentbird sent me musk
therapy by initio parfum's prevase Royal
Forest by English Laundry and gold
expressive by commodity my favorite is
Royal Forest it's got notes of citrus
that kind of sit on a richer bed of
Mason Cedar it's great I smell like a
member of the elk monarchy and I
freaking love it
yay if you're in the U.S or Canada you
can get started finding your fragrance
with scentbird for just a little over
seven dollars for your first month click
the link in the description below and
use coupon code rockstars for 55 off if
you are paying attention there were
actually subtle Clues peppered
throughout the movie leading to this
reveal separate from the stab two
parallels prophesied by Mindy after Tara
blows up at Sam for being too
overbearing and protective Lynn has a
heart to heart with her roomie she tells
her that she understands what it's like
after her brother died her Dad wouldn't
leave her alone either I don't know
Quinn your dad convincing you to become
a murderer to honor your brother isn't
quite the same thing as tasering some
guy in the nards for trying to hook up
with your drunk little sister but you do
you when Sam and Tara make their way to
the precinct after the first wave of
murders they're called by Richie's old
number in the moment it's played like
the new ghost face did the extra leg
work to secure this number but with
hindsight and Occam's razor this trick
is much less elaborate Richie was on his
family's phone plan and officer Bailey
never dropped his number from it after
Quinn's seemingly murdered by Ghostface
officer Bailey emerges from the scene
grief-stricken angry and distraught he
tells Sam and Tara that both of his
children are gone conveniently leaving
out his third child Ethan and swears to
kill Ghostface because if you left with
his family you die this Creed isn't a
lie however Sam killed his precious
little Ricky and he's hell-bent on
making her pay while Ethan didn't say
anything vague about a dead brother to
tip off his connection to Richie looking
back at his character during the rest of
the movie in hindsight is actually kind
of depressing we learned during Bailey's
big villain speech that he favored his
son Richie over Ethan because of his
status as firstborn and he clearly
continued building his son's messed up
Shrine adding murder memorabilia from
Richie and Amber's Scream 5 kills
although it isn't explicitly said it's
pretty apparent that Ethan is an
afterthought to his dad Bailey convinced
him and his sister to recreate The
Golden Child terrific Masterpiece and
become serial killers to honor their
dead brother while Sam eventually
learned to let go of Tara and allow her
to live her own life in the aftermath of
their trauma Bailey dragged his children
down with him and Richie in the final
confrontation of the film we get Sam
taking up her father's blade playing on
the ancestral weapon Trope like Luke
Skywalker using Anakin's lightsaber for
the pop-up kill of this movie we get
Ethan somehow returning from a throat
stab only to get finished off by Kirby
kicking over the same TV that kayods do
back in the first film despite writer
Kevin Williams says confirmation that
Stu is definitely dead in Universe I
stand with Matthew Lillard as a stew
truther and I believe that anything is
possible within the extremely meta
Universe of scream this franchise is all
about undying Legacy baby this is my
Mephisto confirmed the ending of Scream
6 plays with Billy's Darkness still
looming blooming Loomis if you will
within Sam but she's able to let her
past go and move forward but will he
rise again with her in future
installments interestingly one of
Officer Bailey's humble brags about
Richie may have hinted at scream 7's
premise he recalls how his favorite son
inspired others to commit their own
Ghostface murder including Amber Jason
and Greg if these three were influenced
by Richie's Die Hard True Crime
Obsession and so were his father and
siblings there's really no telling how
many other people on the internet heard
his message despite the fact that Sam
discarded Billy's old mask to further
distance herself from her killer Legacy
I wouldn't be surprised if we see more
sick little freaks obsessed with
Richie's gospel come out of the darkness
these are just some of my thoughts on
that wild twist ending in Scream Six but
I want to know what you guys think in
the comments well Sam finally escaped
her father's reflection or will she
slice him up again in Scream 7. will
Richie continue to inspire the next
generation of ghostfaces from Beyond the
Grave will the studio agree to pay Neve
Campbell a fair salary so that she'll
return in the next one why does gale
weather still own a landline thanks to
semford for sponsoring this video check
out the links in the description to
learn more follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Whitney puppy or else follow
me rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
and thanks for watching bye
foreign